what's funny about the Army about the
military is that if you go when they're
skinny you come out heavier and if you
go in there heavy you come out skinnier
in our boot camp platoon if you're fat
you'll go half rations and you'll have
like a thing so when you go to the child
Hall that was Berry steak or whatever
they just cut it in half and give it to
you if you're skinny it's double rations
you walk up oh you get two would you get
in trouble if you share I don't know how
army boot camp is but you can't really
talk yeah because while you're eating we
only have like five minutes
[Laughter]
are you just like swallowing yeah yeah
you can't be like do you want to share
eat it now taste it later five minutes
it's like really one minute first day of
boot camp lunch time I remember getting
a flight full food I was like yes I
can't wait to eat this thing I literally
had like 10 seconds the way they count
is like does it all right everybody on
60 seconds whatever six five four forty
seven oh yeah you can't go time out time
out that's not 60. thank you